[Music]
my friendship yes Tim to the Tim Ferriss
show we've know each other a long time
yes and it's so nice to see you again
and I'm thrilled that we were able to
coordinate uniforms yes with our
respective tailors we will be busking
downtown Austin later today for change
where you are a new citizen yeah lovely
yeah it's a beautiful town yeah it
really is
and you know I thought we would start
and this may seem somber but since this
is something we're just catching up with
maybe an hour ago over lunch can you
talk about your current medical state of
affairs if you wouldn't mind because I
say I think it's a wedge that leads us
into discussions that can be pretty far
ranging sure if you wouldn't mind no no
problem at all on the second day of a
book tour five months ago the day before
I was at Ted speakers dinner a day
before giving a TED talk I found out I
have intermediate stage prostate cancer
and it came as a complete surprise my
urologist had said after doing a biopsy
probably a 20% chance you've got a
problem here but as it turns out I had a
problem and so since then I've had a few
different tests and the good news is I'm
right on the cusp of serious versus sort
of not not serious and so so far we've
just looked at the alternative health
approach but I'm all about Western
medicine but I need to bring the cavalry
across the plantation to to sort of say
yes you know probably I'm young enough
in 58
probably live another 30 to 40 years
probably will have my prostate taken out
in the next couple years what is what
does that feel like to you to realize
her to say and what is that for people
who may not know and what does that mean
I mean it's prostate like an appendix
you don't really need it Hey well it
does have certain functions which we can
get graphic and get into if you want to
but let me say the first of all the Big
C that you know the cancer word is like
what I have cancer and that if good news
is prostate cancer as cancers go
is actually a relatively tame cancer but
that was hard and then prostate you know
the prostate women don't have a prostate
men do and it's part of its it has a
little bit to do with sexual functioning
actually it's more to do with actually
the secretion that happens in semen so
if you have your prostate taken out
you're no longer going to ejaculate
it doesn't mean you still could
potentially have an orgasm but you you
just will have a dry orgasm this is
really crazy this in the first five
minutes
feel like the lace is like this is like
the mirror you know and the friends
cover you know naked nanny or something
skipping the fourth is this is how we
you know keep you on the podcast for an
hour and a half so all I can say is
cancer can be a teacher yeah and for me
it's been a reminder of the
vulnerability that we can have as well
as what level of control you do have
over your body and so the fact that I've
been sort of focusing on making myself
healthier and so far until a couple days
ago this the test results had looked
really good now there's a test result
that PSA square that shows that it's
spiked a little bit so we'll have to
sort of see with an ultrasound this next
week but I think more than anything it
just forces us to ask ourselves or
forces me to ask myself what am I here
on this earth to accomplish and to
experience and it creates a certain
level of urgency in life I had a
flatline experience where I went to the
other side ten and a half years ago and
that did the same thing for me so that
was a st. Louis doesn't st. Louis thank
you for the memory on that one yes as in
st. Louis and I had was been going
through a difficult time and had a
broken ankle from a bachelor party with
Gavin Newsom and I cut on my leg which
had a bacterial infection in it because
Gavin had his bachelor party at 18 d
ballpark where the service occurred
Giants play and I hit a triple out to
the outfield and slid into third base
and broke my ankle but got fertilizer in
my leg on the kite I didn't know and so
so I've had a couple experiences of just
being a wake up call which is an
interesting
term for a hotel EUR uh to have a
wake-up call answers say you know what
you are still alive but are you living
your life the way you want to live your
life and the reason I thought this could
be as good a place as any to start is
that in all my interaction with you from
the very beginning which goes back at
least 10 years probably more I've been
struck by how aware you strive to be of
your thinking and how many times you
have changed chapters very deliberately
and so I thought this could be a segue
into conversations about some of those
chapter changes and how you thought
through them and also just impactful
periods in your life yeah and I thought
maybe if you're willing to I think it
was a quote I could be getting this
wrong so feel free to fact-check but the
Shakespeare quote well yeah that you
shared when we were having lunch which I
think it's beautiful appropriate the
meaning of life is to find your gift and
the purpose of life is to give it away
now it's been actually sometimes been
called Shakespeare sometimes called
Picasso Picasso has a great quote too
that relates to modern elder which is
computers are useless they only give you
answers we'll come back to that one yeah
but but yeah the idea of finding your
gift
the meaning of life is to find your gift
the purpose of life is to give it away
and that I think I've that's been very
much embedded in my heart and a soul in
my mind over my 35 37 years of being in
the business world and for people who
who aren't familiar with with chip what
is what is the introduction the context
you'd like to give or if it's easier how
would someone introduce you at a
speaking it well the way they introduce
me the speaking engagements often is
this is the guy who's disrupted his
favorite industry twice and that
happened that industry happens to be
hospitality I was one of the first
boutique hotels along with Ian Schrager
and Bill Kimpton I started a company
called schwa de vivre sha he was based
in San Francisco created 52 boutique
hotels second largest boutique hotel
here in the US and then after 24 years
of running that soon after I had my
flatline experience
which was a wake-up call to say I didn't
want to be running that company anymore
I was asked six years ago by the three
young founders of Airbnb to come join
them and take their little tech startup
and turn it into a global hospitality
brand so I have been a disrupter twice
and yes so I that's my I've also written
five books and I most recently have
created this the world's first midlife
wisdom school called the modern Elder
Academy and we're gonna talk about all
of this yeah so many places to go I
thought we would start with one of your
more glamorous spirits could you tell us
how you got into commercial real estate
you know I I grew up in California
everybody in California has sort of like
the real estate bug and I went to work
for my son my my uncle the summer and
then almost most of my junior year at
Stanford he was a commercial real estate
developer in Silicon Valley this was
1980 was full of orange groves so I
think I was nothing like it is today and
I just saw everybody making money and
sort of having a good time in commercial
real estate what I was fascinated by was
the creative side of it how do you how
do you design environments and
ultimately I went to Stanford Business
School straight out of undergrad and
focused on real estate there and then
went to work for a real estate developer
in San Francisco for a couple years and
other night after Stanford Business
School and then that's when I said you
know what to think the part of real
estate that's really interesting is
hotels what did you think you were going
to do as an undergrad
did you know real estate was the answer
let's say freshman sophomore year what
did what did you envision adults ship
doing I thought is give me a philosopher
yeah you and I could've hung out
together yeah we could well you are kind
of do a little Seneca you know Marcus
Aurelius debate you know before it was
cool yeah exactly
no I took a class called God's God self
in the body or something like that
freshman year I just loved it I saw that
a lot but you know everybody said like
what are you gonna do with a philosophy
major
so I thought I might go into politics
like helping in a governmental role and
I did a summer in DC as an intern and
didn't love it and so
business became sort of the next thing
and I guess I have been sort of a
philosopher in business I certainly
that's part of reason I like writing
books about it but I know I had no idea
I was gonna get into commercial real
estate and and then at 26 2006 birthday
I finished a business plan to create
this boutique hotel company called
Sherrod Aviv which is a really
impractical name for a company
especially in the US because it's hard
to pronounce hard to spell most people
don't know what it means it means joy of
life but very few companies in the world
have a mission statement that's also the
name of the company mm-hmm and that's
what really resonated with me and yeah
bought a broken-down Motel
pay-by-the-hour motel in the Tenderloin
called it called it the Phoenix and it
became a rock-and-roll hotel and a big
sensation and that's how I got started
so if we back up a little bit and
revisit Stanford Business School in in
the course of preparing for this read
about brainstorming sessions did I think
there were a few hours in length yeah I
hesitate to say four hours because of
course I'm the four-hour guy but I think
in the in the article it was four hours
yes and there were some there were some
other characters involved you've done
your research whose names may be
recognized well I think Seth Godin was
also Seth and I wrote our first we both
wrote our first books together back when
we were in our second year of Business
School yeah the script there's five guys
all we're the five youngest guys in the
class it's two of us I went straight
into business school the other three had
had one year off and we were sort of not
well-liked generally within the business
class because we were just the innocent
naive you know
yeah so we sort of create our own little
Club and we were brainstorming business
ideas and was there was there a format
to it did you guys meet on a regular
basis basis and it was really the best
way to describe it it was each one of us
would I bring an idea to the table and
then we critique it and Seth is a you
know a good critic yeah I'm not very
good critic and so that was partly how
we how I got to know Seth and ultimately
Seth and I didn't love business school
and so are stuck at your business school
we said why don't we write a book get
credits for writing the book use that
experience to go out and interview a
bunch of famous people who
talk to us because we're business school
clue students but once we graduate they
won't talk to us
because I think we're looking for a job
use that Stanford while he can and we
did and we created book called business
rules of thumb and it came out a long
long long time ago
and yeah except that that point had
caught the bug he knew it was gonna
write books I did I hadn't caught the
bug it wasn't until about gosh 16 18
years later that I wrote my what I
consider my first book I don't actually
count that book as one of my five books
unfortunately I don't think Seth counts
as well it's a if people are listening
and they like the idea of forming a
group like this yes and because I think
that at least in the piece that I take a
look at the the consensus of some of the
people in the group was that you learned
more through those sessions than you did
through the the coursework so if people
out there listening and they think they
want to create their own group whether
they call it a mastermind or a
brainstorming group or whatever it might
be where they have the opportunity to
put people say in the hot seat yeah and
to have their ideas critiqued and to
offer the same do you have any
guidelines or recommendations on how to
do that well or what the necessary
ingredients are well I think the most
important thing is to have clarity about
what the purpose is like that's sort of
true in life and true with any business
but it's actually true with a group and
so the fact that we knew this was a
brainstorm around business ideas mostly
entrepreneurial ideas was absolutely
clear if you don't have that clear then
people are using it for different
purposes and it's fine to have different
purposes as long as people know each
other's agenda so I think that's key I
think another thing that's key is is
while it can be like intellectual
jousting and so it can be hardcore there
has to be at least an underlying respect
if the purpose of it is to just you know
skewer each other you know people start
to shut down or start to stop showing up
you know and so that's that's critical
and at the end of the time I also had a
good time I think that was a big piece
of it as well how long did they last
they could I mean what we did it for the
two years and what was the school what
was what was the big if the big purpose
really was I think all five of us wanted
to graduate and become entrepreneurs
straight
Business School I don't think any of us
did that um some of us went to work for
very entrepreneurial ventures but I
think what we really wanted to do is
incubate some interesting ideas such
that in that second year of Business
School we might determine if we were
gonna actually create a business plan I
think probably it did incubate an idea I
had an idea in one of those sessions
where I talked about creating sort of an
urban retreat Resort where people would
go and go to workshops and classes and
and it would be a place where you could
sort of get away from the city but in
the city mm-hmm
there's a place called the Esalen
Institute in Big Sur and I've been on
the board for basically a decade and
I've been teaching there for a long time
it was like book stores dedicated to the
book stores dedicated to me thank you
it is because I gave some money you know
so the bottom line is I said why isn't
there an esslyn in the city and that was
an idea that percolated ultimately it
led me to buying a no-tell motel in the
Tenderloin of San Francisco which is not
exactly that idea but I think it was
this roughly so 84 was when he graduated
so when I think probably came up with
that idea and it was 86 that I came up
with the idea of Jawad Aviv and buying
this motel in the in the Tenderloin so
sometimes you you know you're planting a
seed
I mean what's great about life is you
know your brain your soul your spirit
your ability to channel something deeper
than you from far offs in the in the
cosmos these are things that actually
sometimes take time you know and so
planting seeds early is is wise this is
part of reason I wanted to ask you what
you thought you might be or what grabbed
you as an undergrad because if I'm maybe
I'm forcing a narrative but I don't
think so because I've seen this before
in that you have philosophy it grabs you
it has great appeal but you don't know
what to do with it at the time so you
bookmark it right don't expect to ever
come back to it yeah and then you plan
on X but you can't do it right away and
it seems to me at least for myself I try
to do this if something really excites
me I assume that there's probably a
place for it or a role
it just might have to incubate for a
while exactly the question is timing
yeah and at what form it will take so
yeah I think for me the the thing that
was really interesting is that writing
that book with Seth a second year
incubated 16 or 18 years later in in my
first official book which was called the
rebel rule rules daring to be yourself
in business and Richard Branson wrote
the foreword and I think that for me the
thing that became clear to me was and
has been a practice my whole business
career is making a weekly inventory of
what I learned that week has been
essential and I think that every Friday
afternoon I started doing it when I was
in my mid-20s and I would almost do a
half hour to an hour usually on Friday
afternoon sometimes over the weekend and
said here that some of my key lessons of
the week and I created a wisdom book and
it's called the wisdom book and that
wisdom book was the collection of
lessons that I was learning along the
way and I I it wasn't like I went to the
wisdom book all that often to look at it
I did do it in in dark times I would go
there but generally it was just the act
of putting it down that was planting a
seed in my consciousness to take notice
hmm
when did you stop doing that or did you
still do it you still do it I so if I
may yeah and today's Saturday today's
Saturday stuff where I day I'm a flight
to Austin which I lost the flight missed
the flight oh and had to fly to Houston
and then take a lift from Houston here I
took I did my list and this list was a
really interesting list because this was
a weird week now obviously this is going
to be a on out in the public in a few
weeks
but this week was the week that a New
York Times article came out about my our
new modern Elder Academy and it as
people have said people say it's a great
article but it's not really very
accurate and to my mind a great article
is very accurate so I don't love this
article and I've had forced me to
reacquaint myself with one of Victor
Frankel's famous three line or three
lines from man's search for meaning and
so that went into my lessons this week
which was between stimulus
and response there is a space in that
space is your power to choose your
response and in your response lies your
growth in your freedom and I had to
really watch that ever look at that
those three sentences over and over
because I was just getting more and more
indignant and almost feeling betrayed by
the journalist because you know she just
didn't she didn't she wasn't she didn't
give a factual story so long story short
is I this week my list of lessons were
very much about emotional regulation and
which is really something that we learn
as we get older yeah you know there's a
lot of things that as we get older we
are very aware of the things that
actually get worse with time but we're
actually not as aware of the things the
better with time how long is say the
total set of bullets for this week is it
a page is it two pages it depends on the
week the bloody or the week the more
lights there are the average week is
about five five bullet five bullets of
you know look at that on Fridays Oh
interesting right but my mere bullets
and my bolts are different um my bullets
are really actually lessons yours them
you're not like here's my here's the my
favorite spatula I found this week and
has learned no nothing like that now
they're actually yeah they're deep and
sometimes painful this week there were
probably 12 bullets and and some of you
know some of them are like tactical yeah
are you willing to share anything yeah
like one of them was you know I I said
to my PR person I got this article on my
own you know I know the off the the
journalists and we're not I wouldn't say
we're friends but we know each other
moderately well and I think she'd
probably prefer just the one-on-one and
and she did but I didn't necessarily
have someone there to sort of say hey
yeah chip said these things and why are
those not in the article and you put
something else in there that he didn't
say and so it I think part of it for me
was okay you know yes it's it's normal
to have someone there as a PR specialist
especially for an article as important
as say the New York
times would be that's another example
that I gave the Franklin example you
know another one is when things are
troubled it's the most important time
for who at the higher you are in Oregon
in an organization to become because our
mirror neurons mean that our emotions
are contagious and so and everybody
tends to look at the most senior person
to see how they're reacting to something
and so when something goes askew people
look to the leadership to see you know
are they sweating yeah and I'm not
saying that we shouldn't be authentic
and transparent and but you can be both
vulnerable and a visionary at the same
time you can also be very serious and
calm at the same time yeah for sure if
can be so I think that I've tried to to
be that way and not you know I get like
so wrapped up in a reaction you know
Frankel's quote is really about reaction
you know response versus react and
though the longer were on this earth
often the better we get at being
responsive as opposed to reactive what
what other practices or books or
resources anything at all has helped you
in developing your what was the phrase
you used not emotional resilience
regulation yeah I think I've been lucky
enough and not unlike awful at Yoga
people say oh you got the Yoga body you
sort of seem like you like a yoga guy
and I think I'm really tight I have a
hard time with that and but I'm really
good at meditation and I took to it
thirty-five years ago and I've
integrated into my life ever since then
and I would say a morning practice of
just meditating as well as sometimes an
afternoon practice or a practice when
I'm most stirred up is to just close my
eyes give myself ten minutes to just
absolutely get into a mantra of just
breathing and you know that actually is
a way of you know regulating myself
clearly exercise you know and just
getting it out of your system and
getting out of your brain I mean so much
of emotional regulation is learning to
get out of your brain and
and so that's I've done that too but I
would say back to the yoga for a second
I I think there's two ways that I look
at life and that's to be in
entertainment mode trying to attain
something and in an atonement mode and
what I found is that I'm my natural
tendency is very attain oriented you
know and when I'm in the attain mode I
often have to atone afterwards I guess I
have sharp elbows and I'm just going for
what I want attain and when I turn or a
tone was attained yeah it leads to
atonement a tune leads to at one and
there's so for me that's been something
for about a year now I've been able to
sort of see myself and so ask myself am
i stirred up because I'm in the attained
mode attain is perfectly fine yet
Yoga is not an attained sport surfing
which I at age 57 56 57 and 58 now I
started learning to surf this is not an
attained sport the key is to attune
yourself to the wave you know and so
recognizing when you're supposed to be
in the attain mode and when you're
supposed to be in the attune mode is
something that I think I've learned over
time hmm and is your meditation practice
mostly focusing on the breath and
letting arise whatever arises without
trying to modify it or what is your what
is your internal practice I like when
you sit for this 10 minutes I have a lot
you know so the 20 so I've done TM ins
that that's a 20 minute practice and
that's the that's sort of my core the
[ __ ] is it I do yeah but a mantra based
try do it morning and afternoon at
minimum I do it the morning the I do a
lot of other ones as well there's a
loving-kindness meditation that I you
know sometimes will do which when
frankly when I'm most stirred up about
someone in particular I could sort of go
that that direction I loved the pasta
but that's more of an extended silent
meditation practice and I like right now
two years ago I was in Loretto Bay in
Baja kayaking with a guy named Mark
Coleman who wrote a book called awake in
the wild beautiful book packing with him
and 12 of us from island to island
amongst whales with a silent cracking
meditation retreat for a week didn't
talk for a week that was beautiful
so I think but but at the simplest thing
to do I think of two things it's just
it's breathing learning how to breathe
the thing that I do that's the chip
Conley a little trademark is I think of
louvered windows in my forehead hold on
look what windows louvered like you know
you know like sort of glass louvered
windows so you sort of open them and
they just sort of like they turn and
good so actually the reason I like them
is we have them at the Phoenix hotel him
I was gonna said they're sort of like
the they make me think of really old
Volkswagen yeah camper buses that have
that type of rotational window exactly
so you have a rotation like the vents in
an air conditioning duct in a car
exactly imagine that on your forehead
okay and so what I do is I breathe
through my forehead and then I breathe
out my forehead and this is how I turn
down the heat on my brain I mean surely
this is like my the chip Conley approach
or whatever works work yeah so that's
you know but yes I these the the core
thing I tend to do is the the TTM and
for people who are interested in in the
second you mentioned which is
loving-kindness meditation also known or
called meta and then it's M et ta there
are some fantastic guided meditations
that you can listen to out there like
jack Kornfield has some fantastic
versions of that there's also a really
fascinating guy named chade-meng tan who
wrote a book called joy on demand to go
that gets into this and search inside
yourself to search inside yourself which
became the most popular employee class
at Google at one point a waiting list of
like six to 12 months or something like
that so let's let's go back to something
you mentioned your first book the first
book you count how old were you and you
wrote that roughly I was 38 when I wrote
it
and yeah and I'd been running my company
for a dozen years thought Aviv and how
did you get Richard Branson to read the
fourth great question you know so Gavin
Newsom at that point he was the mayor of
San Francisco and I he was my first
mentee I was a mentor to him indeed so
we went together
to see him and give a talk at the Virgin
Records store in San Francisco I
remember that he used to exist so it was
actually around the launch of that
record store you know it's hard to
remember it on Market Street yeah I've
learned like a record store really it
wasn't that long ago though but um so we
went there and we were there with like
the head of protocol for the city
actually this was before Gavin was mayor
he was just on the Board of Supervisors
in San Francisco and we I don't know he
just took a liking to both of us
and so he said you know can we hang out
how did you meet him in person we were
literally in line to actually have him
sign our book and it was me and Kevin
and so when we came up he just ended up
spending a bunch of time with us and he
we waited a little bit later and he
talked with us just the two of us and we
went out and had a meal I'm gonna keep
chipping away at this no pun intended so
you walk up you're good with words
Gavin is also good with words so you
guys walk up there's a long line of
people what do you say or ask that gets
the attention of someone or what is the
presence that you put forth that gets
the attention of someone language or
president who in that environment is
IKEA the King I can't remember the names
right now but I learned his parents
names his mother and his father and so I
went and I knew there was something in
the front line and I said so what
influence did so-and-so and so-and-so
have on who you are today and he looked
at me like how do you know that so that
led to the conversation is led to a
longer conversation was amazing did you
propose hanging out after the signing or
did he did you the next day so and we
just had lunch the next day and and the
truth is that his company verge was just
in the early stages I think I'm thinking
about doing Virgin America the the
airline and I was at that point the
largest hotelier in San Francisco in
terms of the number of hotels we had so
it was there was some there's some
benefit to him as well how did you make
the jump from him being impressed that
you knew his parents names to meeting
the next day you know actually he had an
assistant there and so and his assistant
actually did know me and knew Gavin so
she was like wise
- no silat a teaser - and she said so he
said can you go talk to April over there
and so we went over and talked to April
and April said you know what he's got
some time to schedule tomorrow and so
amazing yeah and then flash for and you
know forward from Richard Branson so
yeah he alternates ed you know I'll
write it but you're gonna write the
first that first draft and you know and
and then he edited it and it went in it
alright so we're gonna get continue this
this forward and backwards chronology if
I can even call it such who's Brenda Lee
and this may go somewhere it may not go
anywhere but Brenda Lee is this four
foot ten inch
although she's five foot six with her
beehive hairstyle Nashville Gow famous
country-western singer and out of the
blue her bus her pink bus was driving
through the Tenderloin in San Francisco
looking for a place to stay and this is
about a month after we opened my first
hotel the Phoenix paint a picture of the
Tenderloin at this point well it's
changed that much a lot of drugs on the
street and it's a relatively poor
neighborhood pretty desolate but it's
right in the middle of the city it's
right and it's right near Union Square
and in the hotel district so we were
sort of we were the Gateway to the
Tenderloin but we were on the opposite
side of the Tenderloin from where the
nicer part of the Tenderloin and Union
Square was so she's driving through
there and I'm looking for a place to
stay and she wanted a motel and we were
a motel she comes in she had no idea
that our aspiration was to be a rock and
roll hotel and so she comes in and we
had weirdly enough I got in arlo guthrie
staying at the hotel on the same time
listen to Arlo go through when I grew up
so our logo threes in the hotel because
the great American music cost two blocks
away Brenda Lee comes in with her bus
and we have bus parking so one of the
beautiful things about the phoenixes ad
free bus parking which bands gonna
appreciate and she checks in and all of
a sudden we'd become a rock-and-roll
hotel we had our logo through him Brenda
Lee and that led to you know Nirvana
Pearl Jam
you know David Bowie Red Hot Chili
Peppers you know everybody you can
imagine whatever this is the way you
tell the story it's like they ship up
and then all of a sudden were
rock-and-roll hotel I know there's more
to the story there's more the story
no no so how did okay so they you you
have manifested or chanced upon this
lock of having these two guests at the
same time yeah how do you how does that
then get converted into a reputation
do they just recommend to other people
do you seize upon that hey could we take
some photos how does it there's logic so
my business school brain was saying okay
well who's the person who books all of
the hotel rooms for bands coming through
town and and Brit I'd gotten in a bill
Graham who's a music impresario a
concert promoter and he had said well
it's usually the concert you know
whoever's booking the concert they're
doing it so I tried to we tried to
market to them then we tried to market
to the venues like Slim's or the great
American Music Hall or the film war that
made sense and then we found out others
these travel agents who specialize in
entertainment travel so let's go to
market to them to be honest with you
none of those worked all that well they
worked okay the number one thing that
worked this is so funny was the person
who typically made the decision of where
the band was going to stay was the the
tour manager so the tour manager was
usually a guy almost always a guy about
three to five years older than the band
his job is to make sure there was no
overdoses and no groupies and because a
groupie might mean the guy like doesn't
show up at the show and of course an
overdose could do that as well
and he was by the time he got to San
Francisco he was so stressed out because
usually the tour started on the East
Coast and by the time he got the service
so here's what we did we had one room of
our 44 rooms that was a massage
treatment room now back in the old days
when it was a pay-by-the-hour place you
can imagine what happened in there but
we cleaned it up ally made into a
legitimate massage studio and so we
offered to tour managers when you bring
your band here if you give us ten room
nights five rooms times two nights you
get a free massage for yourself and so
back in the day when we started doing
that now remember this is pre cell
phones free internet pre frankly laptop
computers people had satellite phones
but mainly what they were doing was
going on the house front and the turn
managers calling his friends and then
sometimes writing a letter and sending
it out to them in old-school US mail and
saying there's this place in San
Francisco that actually gives you a free
massage and that's what I realized that
really great entrepreneurs don't deliver
on your expectations well they'd
hopefully do they deliver on your
expectations they deliver in your
desires but the thing they get right is
this thing at the peak of the pyramid I
wrote a book called peak how great
companies get their mojo from as oh it's
meeting the unrecognized needs of
whomever your customer is and in my case
figuring out that the customer was not
all those other people it's actually the
tour manager and what's is that
unrecognized need it's basically to like
chill and to relax and they get a free
massage that's incredible and yeah
because it it also acts as a contrast in
my mind to a maxim that is often often
used but I think often inaccurate which
is you granted you how to you had this
Motel slash hotel but you need money to
make money but if you look at what you
did in that particular case I mean you
identified who your actual customer was
it's likethey the the unspoken customer
yeah right and no one told me no one
ever said that was the term out yeah and
then the UH the unspoken need and the I
mean the cost to offer that service yeah
it's just a rounding her I love you know
it's a great it's a great
entrepreneurial story to sort of suggest
that sometimes it's not the thing that's
most obvious and it's not the thing
that's the most expensive yeah
but this idea of the unrecognized need
how do you mind read your customer well
enough to know what it is that they
would love we have a hotel later that we
created which you and I've been to the
hotel Vitaly here which is on the
waterfront in San Francisco I don't know
if to my books there oh thank you yeah
well so long as you're sure the hotel
Batali like the Phoenix is in market
worst neighborhood in San Francisco and
vitality sort of like the best
neighborhood it's right on the bay
on the on the Embarcadero right
questions of Ferry Building and
the farmers market so the unrecognized
need for the customer we wanted there so
the vitaly means vitality in latin or an
italian and we wanted to create a hotel
that was sort of what we called for the
person who was post w and pre four
seasons you know david brooks we call
him the bourgeois bohemian so the bobo
then we the the hospitality tweeners yes
the husband who sort of was looking for
that and so our point of view was we
said this is a person who reads real
simple and dwell so it's actually
probably more female-oriented
and it's a female business traveler and
if there are five adjectives to define
those two magazines modern urbane fresh
natural and nurturing that describes
this person and so we ended up creating
on the top floor of the hotel vitaly
when we launched fifteen years ago a
yoga studio on the penthouse level that
had free yoga classes every morning now
my my investors looked at me like
they're all guys looked at me like what
are you doing now
today this might make sense twenty years
ago when we work on cepting this they're
saying like there is no financial
district hotel in the world that has a
yoga studio on the on the on the on the
penthouse level like why would we ever
do that
and i said well because we're gonna be
the first ones doing it and so then they
said we'll look at all of the customer
satisfaction forms you've gotten from
people in financial district hotels and
have they asked for a yoga studio and
the answer is no ten thousand of them we
looked at ten thousand not one person
ever said why don't you have a yoga
studio in your hotel yeah but if you're
good and if you really understand your
customer it goes beyond the expectations
beyond the desires beyond focus groups
it's the thing you know that they want
next but they don't even know they don't
want right well no they want well so
long story short is the yoga studio had
a line out the door and within a month
we had we were in you know New York
Times LA Times Wall Street Journal had
stories about this new sort of hotel
that's oriented toward business
travelers who want to stay healthy and
the hotel Vitale ended up becoming the
most successful upscale hotel in San
Francisco it's it's it's reminiscent to
me of and this could be apocryphal I
don't know if this is a real anecdote
it's kind of like every quote is
attributed to Abraham Lincoln or Oscar
Wilde on the
but no they had a thing between them a
quote off Henry Ford I think you know if
I had asked people what they wanted them
have set a faster board yeah I always
can't ask him and to to look under the
under the hood on that decision a little
bit so the the first is and this is
something that I'm constantly maybe
constantly is too strong word but I
always consider when I'm looking at
launches or books or television shows or
documentaries whatever it is is being
first I think the the doing something
the first time is really can be really
undervalued like the the being second
different story right being first it can
be very very newsworthy in and of itself
also what would you have done if it if
it hadn't worked we would have turned it
into a space right I mean so the key the
key there and it's that you just said it
exactly right which is my point to my
investors was give me six months let me
try this we can ratchet and make it into
a suite and it that in fact after we
sold the hotel a bunch of years later
that's what they did but I said give me
that time because this was not gonna be
insurmountable if it didn't work out but
it turned out to be it turned it to
package and position the brand of the
hotel really well and be something that
people valued and but I think the point
on that is to sort of say okay so how do
you try things and and do something
small enough but that could have a big
impact that is easily solvable if it
doesn't work right and which is also
something that can be tied into Richard
Branson right because people think of
Richard Branson as this throw caution to
the wind maverick who risks it all
despite the odds and he's put on the
podcast but I you've spent time with
them and if you look at I believe it was
Virgin Atlantic where he hated he took
so many in between steps
to cap the downside on something that
could be unmitigated a complete disaster
right Airlines
it's like magazines restaurants like you
can really lose your shirt and among
other things you know tested with I
thought want to see like a poster board
in an airport when I flight was canceled
something like Virgin Airlines and it
was a chartered flight that he was going
to book if he got enough people to sign
up for you know the eight or ten seats
that it would take did that successfully
and then negotiated with I want to say
was Boeing at the time in order to be
able to give them back the plan hmm if
it didn't work right so behind the
scenes he's actually making very very
calculated bets he's a shrewd guy super
shrewd yeah and I think you know that
one of the things I learned from my dad
a long time ago is build the business
plan as if it's not going to succeed
I mean imagine it succeeding and you're
gonna attract people for that for
investors employees but what's plan B
you know and and how do you how do you
have a solution for Plan B and so that's
why I don't build bowling alleys in
terms of the shape for them yeah you can
sit in the past churches but churches
have become sort of popular for all
kinds of uses post Church era but yeah I
think it's really critical to sort of
understand what is plan B C and D so
let's talk about another chapter shift
and I'm gonna take this opportunity to
pull up a screenshot of a text exchange
that I had with a mutual friend of ours
with Liz yes so could you explain for
people who don't know who who is is just
so Liz Lambert hates me because she even
said on your podcast Yeats me because I
did for her what now I hope and expect
she does for other people which is she
reached out to me almost twenty years
ago I would had become a successful
entrepreneur hotelier a boutique hotel
and she was creating this funky little
motel here in an Austin called the hotel
San Jose and similar to my Phoenix and
she liked what we did with the Phoenix
although she was going to something was
a little more upscale
and she wanted my help and so I came
here and gave her some suggestions and
then I actually sent my general manager
from the Phoenix monica bernstein down
here to us and basically to help her get
lodged why why did you do that I she
wasn't here for that long but she was
here for I don't you know I can't
remember but like weeks at the time I
did it partly because I loved Liz
you know I loved you know she's an
attorney who should never have been an
attorney who's completely amazing as a
designer so she's one of those hotel
yers who designs her own hotels which I
love that so like you know that like a
restaurant tour where the chef is the
restaurant tour so I think it's really
beautiful and so I just loved her
passion and her sense of the you know
hers right Aviv frankly heard that they
shed I'd took it such a joy in what she
was doing and I wanted her to succeed
and so you know I am a big believer in
Kermit capitalism which means sort of
what goes around comes around and so me
giving to Liz was gonna pay back to me
some in some way over time and and
frankly it's been me doing that with a
lot of different people and then having
it come back reputationally you know
your reputation is one of the few things
in your life that's portable and frankly
it rides FedEx before you arrive
somewhere because that's what happens
with the reputation people know you
before you arrive and I think that
whether it's Liz or a variety of other
people who I have tried to help in
business it's just helped my reputation
in terms of how people see me and
instead of people standing on the
sidelines sort of like jeering they're
they're cheering they they want you know
when when the New York Times article
came out this week and I didn't love it
I had a such a support network of people
who just said you know what we're gonna
write letters the editor because it's
not a bad article chip but you don't
want it's not accurate and they wanted
to help and I think you know I once had
a restaurant tour co-founded a
restaurant with someone and no one
really liked her she was actually very
shrewd really tough negotiator but when
she launched a restaurant if she got a
bad review people were sort of silently
happy and I don't I'm not that way and
I'm not saying that to say I'm the most
likable person in the world but I will
absolutely say that I do a lot of things
to make that Kermit capitalism work for
me in the world and as such
liz was just an example of that and and
the part reason she hates me is because
now she feels the obligation to pass it
on pay it forward to someone else
because she gets you know hit up all the
time because she's just an amazing hotel
she's really incredible and she's done
he's called bunk house bunk house and
she has a number of just incredible not
just incredible properties but
incredibly different yeah they're
they're soulful you know at the end of
one of her pools you know the st.
Cecilia pool here in Austin just says
you know neon soul and there's something
soulful to her places and so I want to
bet on people like that
yeah yeah there there are a lot of
parallels that I can see looking at the
two of you side-by-side in some ways and
I just just struck me that I did a
number of staycations at Hotel Vitale to
work on books because I think I had read
that Maya Angelou had done that and I
thought that's a great idea
yes at home I have all the usual
distractions and ways to procrastinate
let me treat this Moby would do that
when he's playing Moby would do that
he'd go to a hotel room and just show
himself off for a week and to actually
figure out music no kid so I have
friends here I won't mention their names
but they're well-known filmmakers
because they told me this just in a
private conversation who use Hotel Saint
Cecilia mmm for their sort of staycation
creative work as well so I'm gonna jump
to this text from Liz she had a number
of questions I asked her are there any
particular questions or topics that you
think could be interesting or fun to
explore so one of them she gave me quite
a few but one of them was he
meaning you began building joie de vivre
as a young man it was the work of the
first half of his life a big sprawling
family what made him decide to sell it
when he did so a great question you know
the one thing you know to you aspiring
entrepreneurs and people who are younger
than me just know that when you one of
the natural tendencies is we hook our
sense of self-esteem and self-worth to
our businesses I remember in the early
days of the Phoenix I had won a hotel
before I had 52 and that one hotel when
people's people come to me and say how
you doing chip I said well the Phoenix
is doing fine
and finally somebody called me on it's
like you know it's like I didn't say how
I'm doing so my sense of Worth and
esteem had a lot to do with basically
the rollercoaster of my business well
fortunately over time I realized that
didn't have to be the case and it was
that flatline experience I had 22 years
into running my company that helped me
to see that is this what I want to do
the rest of my life actually it's not
and I thought it was gonna be but it
wasn't and more than anything I just
realized that I started the company for
creativity and freedom that's what those
are the things I said to myself on one
Friday afternoon and I said well you
know what did I learn this week about
why I'm starting this business and 22
years later I said do I have any
creativity freedom in this business
anymore no I'm like running a company
with 3,500 people so that's what led me
it was hard though is very hard to sell
a business that furet you know
ultimately when I sold it was 24 years
that has been your identity for most of
your adult life but it was actually
harder for other people than for me and
that's a fascinating piece of it is I
realized my identity had moved on I was
ready for what's next which was to
become the world's leading expert on
festivals and I didn't really want to be
doing it anymore but I had to deal with
other people's challenge in me changing
my identity and there's lots of ways
people change your identity you can get
divorced you can you know change your
career completely you can literally
change your gender but in my case it was
just changing the actual fact that I was
the founder and CEO of what was the
largest boutique hotel company second
largest in the in the US but the largest
hotel company frankly in the same Cisco
Bay area and for some people who liked
having their friend have that role and
got a lot of free hotel rooms out of it
from me or restaurant reservations or
massages as my spas they didn't like it
and but at the end of the day it was the
right decision said that that as you
just said it sounds like a difficult
decision or a maybe emotionally intense
decision to work through and I mean I
remember when this was kind of happening
and and you mentioned just in passing
here you know I decided what I want to
do next she's become the worldwide
expert on festivals did you need to find
that before you are comfortable on some
level with making the decision to move
on or did you make the decision to move
on pull the trigger and then find that
next thing yeah no that's a great
question III made the decision I had
this was gonna kill me if I kept doing
it and so I knew I needed to move on I
didn't know it and and frankly then you
get into the freaky in the Great
Recession the freaky thought of like how
am I gonna sell this company in the
bottom of the recession so I hadn't yet
found the new thing I was moving toward
I would know what I was moving away from
but moving towards something is really
important because otherwise when you do
leave it you actually it's like when
people retire and they end up on a golf
course depressed yeah because they
actually didn't move towards something
they just moved away from something and
they just sort of sort of like almost
you know just wasting their time you
know there's in a void they stepped into
it they stepped in to avoid and so I the
fact that I got to a place where
ultimately I said you know what I'm
fascinated with festivals I'm on the
board a Burning Man and there's no great
website for all the world's best
festivals maybe I'll just go around and
become the world's most interesting
person and go around to festivals all
over the world and I did that 36
festivals in 20 countries in one year
and that helped me of a great blog post
on Tim blog about some of your
experiences festivals I do a that's
right exactly yeah so I loved love that
process and it did help me move to
what's next personally wrote another
book a book called emotional equations
that did well became a New York Times
bestseller and it was another thing that
just listed like this is my I new
identity I'm you know at that point that
was my fourth book it was like okay yeah
I write I speak I go to festivals I live
a good life you know stop you know
giving me [ __ ] for the fact that I'm no
longer a boutique hotel yeah so you
mentioned the emotional equation so I
remember this and could you explain
despair equals suffering - meaning yeah
when I had that flatline experience and
and to just give I was in st. Louis
giving a talk I basically probably had
an allergic reaction to an antibiotic
for my
septic leg and my broken ankle and I
went to the other side nine times over
the course of when were you when this
happened as in I mean did you make it to
the hospital before you valent no so I
was I so I was I was giving a speech on
crutches which is what first sign that
chip should have been staying in bed and
not on this book tour Jeff was like yeah
why was that crutches on stage giving a
speech so I didn't fortunately I did not
fall over at the speaker as I was
standing up at the mic but I sat down
signing books and that's when I slept in
my chair and then they put me I probably
didn't have a flatline experience there
I just went unconscious for three
minutes
fortunately the paramedics showed up a
couple minutes later and really quickly
and they put me on a gurney and they had
put heart monitors on me and that's the
first time of nine times that I went
flatline and they had to get the paddles
out the first time they didn't have to
use them about five seconds later my
heart came again but over the course of
the next 90 minutes in the ambulance in
the ER etc and I kept saying okay this
is what I saw on the other side and they
ever was there would take a note of it
and turns out was the same thing over
and over again but long story short
we'll hold on let's not do long story
for you can't be long story short
experiences what you see on the other
side there isn't by the way a festival
of the neared pilgrimage of the
near-death experience in Spain Spain as
the weirdest festivals in the world
what I saw was this and in fact it
happened over to get over again means
it's pretty remarkable and worthy to
just talk about it so I don't love the
mountains I love the beach Mountains are
okay I do like it I love being in nature
so it's interesting this is a mountain
setting so it's a mountain setting a
chalet with a huge sunroof or skylight
and light is pouring in the skylight
beautiful light and it's pouring in in
such a way that there's actually this
viscous oil very heavy oil on the ground
on the most beautiful wood grained floor
you've ever seen and it's because the
the way the lights coming in and it's
hitting the floor this oil that serves
slightly moving
or it's like going down these stairs
these beautiful wood stairs it's casting
this beautiful kaleidoscope of colors on
the wall and so what I see is light I
see colors and I see this weird as
frangipani
scented oil going down these stairs and
that's what I kept saying and I never
saw anybody else didn't see anybody on
the other side I what I saw myself is
observing almost floating above this I
felt incredibly peaceful and everything
was moving very very very slow motion so
and I you know I kept coming back to
that and I don't really I've never
actually sat down was like a dream
analysis or anyone's ass or say it
wasn't mean the fact it stares going
downstairs means I may be going to hell
but actually was up I was up at the
mountain Chalet way up toward heaven I
don't I don't know all I know is you
know forget about heaven hell what I
know is in that moment I felt beauty and
calmness like I'd never felt before him
so yeah that so the I was in what did
you make of that like I mean it and I'm
not saying it there there is no weather
if you had a frightened for it in dream
analyst here and they said you know what
that means let me tell you I'd be like
[ __ ] come on I can give us your
opinion yeah it's how much what would
you what did you what do I take from it
yeah what I take from it that I how I
want to honor and experience beauty in
my whole life
you know I'd the gods of efficiency
which I tend to tend to be my religion
these gods and efficiency have a
tendency to force me or have its way
with me in terms of just getting very
clipped and how I do things because I
have to like get all these things done
and you know being clipped and doing
things doesn't allow for the time to
sort of you know have the immediacy of
seeing in that moment that beautiful
thing so I think what it's helped me to
see is like how do I create beautiful
moments in my life
and how do I take time you know to do
you know fasting day three day three or
four days fasting in a row and things
like that that allow me to just be in
the moment that's one thing number two
is
the calmness I felt so no fear of like
okay you know and I'm dying and it's
just gonna be terrible there was that
but I think the thing that was most
interesting was just the fact that the
oil was moving so slowly it's like
there's a there's a ketchup commercial
anticipation a long time ago maybe Heinz
57 ketchup it was like it took so much
work to get that damn ketchup out of the
bottle that's how it felt and so what it
felt for me was like I'm slowly moving
to my death but it's a long time from
now and so that's what I take from it
which is a positive you know overall
perspective that night after having all
those experiences I'm by myself in a in
a in a room at the hospital in st. Louis
and weirdly enough in my backpack that I
brought with me on this trip was man's
search for meaning Viktor Frankl's book
and the reason it was there is because
I'd gone through a few really rough
months and one of my closest friends who
was my insurance agent whose name is
chip had committed suicide four months
earlier and so I was trying to make
sense of my life and so here I had this
book and as I'm reading this book I had
a hard time sleeping that night I'm
reading this book and I was just
distilling if I were to take the meaning
of that book man's search for meaning
and turn it into an equation it would be
despair akuel suffering - meaning and
the way I thought of it is suffering is
sort of a constant if you're a Buddhist
and I start slightly I'm if you're you
believe that suffering is always
ever-present it's the first noble truth
of Buddhism and yet meaning or suffering
and meaning are actually in there sort
of inversely proportional to each other
so if you do the math of like okay
suffering despair equal suffering -
meaning eight equals 10 minus two if you
take two and turn it to four then eight
becomes six right and so despair goes
down when meaning goes up and this is
when I realized that that practice I've
had since you know being a 23 year old
of writing my what my lessons were for
the week was a practice that actually
was giving me meaning and that's that
equation which I came up with that night
what I ended up teaching it to all of
our leaders in the company as we went
into the Great Recession
and ultimately I said Darin I went to to
Bhutan to study the Gross National
Happiness index because I wanted to see
what what's the happiness you know
equation in life and I ended up giving a
TED talk about that and then I ended up
deciding to write this book which was a
series of eighteen equations that sort
of help you make sense of your emotions
whether it's happiness or disappointment
or wisdom are there any other equations
that you find yourself referring to or
thinking of more often yeah I'd say a
couple eggs I D ones very relevant in
the business world and that's anxiety
equals uncertainty times powerlessness
so it's not a plus it's it's a x so the
uncertainty and the powerlessness
together are combustible so what I help
people to see if they're in that space
is what is it that you can try to find
some certainty about and what is it
where you can what what ways can you
actually create some influence and some
sense of power and by doing that you
actually help people get to a place
where they have a little bit less
anxiety makes it very tangible right it
makes it tangible or disappointment
equals expectations - reality that's a
classic one for any business like okay
what's your customer expectation and
then what is it you're giving as a
reality and if the disappointment is
more predominant than the reality then
you know they're going to be there's
going to be I'm sorry if the
expectations are high and reality is low
disappointment this is what will come
from that so and those both are negative
the happiness one I in that I learned in
in Bhutan was happiness equals wanting
what you have / having what you want
wanting what you have speaks to
gratitude having what you want is the
process and of gratification so it's not
to say this is not the exo so it says
gratitude is better than gratification
well that's fine if you're a Buddhist
that's fine if you don't want to go out
and attain attain attain I want to go to
attain and I want to go gratify but but
gratification doesn't necessary
happiness I may bring success and for a
lot of people who think that success
will break happiness you know they go on
the hedonic treadmill and end up
realizing just when they get the thing
that they thought they wanted
some new shiny object in comes the new
thing the rabbit leading the Greyhound
around the trek just sped up a little
bit we know that occasionally we go
there well you know it's it's you me Liz
and a few million people who might be
listening to this
and speaking of lists so this ties in
very very nicely yeah see both you and
Liz are very thoughtful and mm make a
point of trying to be aware of your own
thought processes reasons for doing
things the drivers sort of behind the
superficial answers that were all
inclined to give ya that are fast and
easy and expedient so one of her
questions was I noticed the chip has
made a few life changes selling joie de
vivre Airbnb yet now doing what you're
doing for what looks from the outside
like a conscious choice to simplify his
life slow down a bit but does he always
jump into something else big and
sprawling I know a lot of people in
parentheses like me I suspect just can't
help themselves how do we learn to just
be still
should we is that the goal Wow how do
you yeah how do you how do you begin to
think about that
I want to wring her [ __ ] neck no I'm
kidding but this is I think something
that a lot of people who become good at
achieving struggle with Oh totally
you know I Peter Guber I got to
interview him on stage he's one of them
no well actually you know Peter Guber
yeah we actually have both in his box at
the Warriors games I interviewed him on
stage and this guy's 20 years older than
me and it's been successful in so many
different ways and I was interviewing
them at stage at the Airbnb open which
is our big host open that I was in
charge of 20,000 people in LA at this
one and some on stage this guy and
listening to him and thinking oh my god
that could be me someday and he's an
amazing guy but he's constantly so
driven to succeed at the next thing and
so what I took from that
what I take from Liz's question is I
think the real question here is not
whether you're going to just be still
I love being still the fact I'm a
meditator the fact that I have chosen to
live in Baja California an hour north of
of Cabo San Lucas on the beach learning
how to surf and having a very simple
life there means there's been a lot of
conscious choice of how I'm curating my
life not living in San Francisco anymore
and yeah I have these ideas that I feel
like I want to go out and try in the
world but the question is how am i
executing on them and what is my intent
or what's this sort of the silent intent
for why I'm doing it and I think for so
many of the things I've done in the past
certainly joie de vivre was at times an
exercise in seeing how big chips ego
could get now I say that not to beat
myself up but I do say that from the
perspective of I was this guy who was
getting a lot of my sense of self-worth
from the fact that this hotel company
was successful and so my ego was on
display and then I joined Airbnb because
the farmers asked me to and all of a
sudden I'm not you know I was the tiny
version of Richard Branson in my company
but now I'm like instead of being the
sage on the stage I'm the guide on the
side and I'm helping these three
co-founders take their little tech
company and turn it into a global
hospitality brand and I realized in that
process that I'm still driven I'm still
totally in it although I actually was
learning how to not do the 70 hours a
week kind of thing not four hours a week
or whatever so I what I was realizing is
that actually I'm not doing this for ego
purposes I actually feel like I'm doing
this more for legacy purposes I'm doing
this to actually help them and I believe
in their mission they are being the
mission to belong anywhere help people
belong anywhere and turn strangers into
friends all of that was good and now
this modern Elder Academy that I'm doing
in Baja that she's reciting there you
know the reality is yeah it's it is me
being driven again
but I've put guard posts on it I'm doing
it in Baja I'm doing one location I'm
not doing multiple locations and you
feel comfortable with that commitment I
feel come ya know I am actually in
frankly the cancer you know for those
you didn't hear earlier on the thing
I've got cancer the cancer sort of was
another educator of saying yeah I think
midlife wisdom schools are a thing for
the future in a huge way I think the
idea of lifelong learning and how do we
go to a retreat that helps us to
repurpose ourselves reframe our mindset
to have a growth mindset about you know
our aspirational aging ahead of us I
think all that's important no one's done
that yet there's all there's been all
kinds of retreat centers but not a place
as a curriculum from people in midlife
when you say midlife let's put an age
range you know that haha well before it
doesn't have to be age but how would you
how does someone know if they're in
midlife as is they're in crisis is it a
no you know midlife is historically been
defined as either 40 to 60 or 45 to 65
the truth is the the the phrase midlife
crisis was coined in 1965 and the reason
that didn't exist before then it was
because longevity in the u.s. was 47
years old in the year 1900 and it became
a 77 by the year 2000 we get we added 30
years of longevity in one one century so
what happened is this new era of life
sort of got merged right it's not it's
not yet fade to black it's like no you
have another yeah half the movie to go
what you doing and the thing that it
happens in midlife and how you know
you're in midlife whatever the ages is
you feel the weight of the accumulation
of what you have acquired in your life
and I don't mean just the physical
things I mean the friends the
responsibilities the identities like the
you know sort of invisible nametags that
define who you are in the world and you
actually frankly are sort of feeling
overwhelmed by all of that accumulation
there's this reset that happens in
midlife and and you could say frankly
with the millennial generation it might
happen actually earlier in life it might
happen at 35 frankly in Silicon Valley
it absolutely happened in the mid 30s
when especially if you're an engineer
where you feel like wow I am the locker
you know I'm no longer perceived as you
know an up-and-comer
and in an industry that you know it's
like the entertainment industry or
fashion or professional sports yeah
exactly so you so I think personally
midlife is from 35 to 75 and part of the
reason I think and I think it used to be
just 45 to 65 it's it's happening
younger because of the fact that people
feel irrelevant earlier in you know the
digital intelligence that we desire in
companies mean that there's a greater
and greater desire to hire the new
digital natives and and I think it's
gonna last longer midlife because if
we're gonna live to a hundred which is
sort of the the future you know as a
longevity we're in the right around 80
right now but by the by the time we get
to the end of the century I I think will
be about a hundred for longevity in the
u.s. that means at age 75 you're
probably still working yeah
and at least you know by choice or by
necessity you know creating I mean doing
something so I think that that period
time so midlife used to be a crisis now
it's a marathon and that's ultimately
what led me to saying you know but we
need to figure out this wisdom school
how do people go into midlife and not
think of it life as being just a one
tank journey like you fuel up with all
of your you know education and support
up to age 20 or 25 and then you drive
this vehicle that we call our bodies for
the rest of our lives and at midlife
you're starting to run on fumes and you
need a you need a pit stop and so the
modern Elder Academy is the idea of that
pit stop and I think it's going to help
to create a new category of academia and
or even hospitality real estate which is
the midlife wisdom school just like
Canyon Ranch forty years ago Mel
Zukerman overweight accountant from LA
wanted to go to a place to be get
healthy and all the places that he saw
40 years ago mostly like fat farms and
mostly for women and he ended up
creating Canyon Ranch
in Tucson and it really sort of it
basically created a new hospitality
real-estate category called the
destination spa resort spas has existed
for thousands of years but not a
category of real estate called
destination spa resort so I think that's
what I'm trying to do so to
to answer in the long winded way Liz's
question when I see something like that
and I can see that I can be a social
entrepreneur that's actually trying to
fix a societal ill which is ageism and
people getting stuck in midlife I'm
gonna do that in this case I'm doing it
you know as a social entrepreneur with a
social enterprise where 60% of the
people are on scholarship
so I'm funding a million dollars a year
in scholarships that that is something I
wanted that on but I want to bet on it
as a catalyst for others to do their
thing just that's what I was gonna yeah
is that like Burning Man created a bunch
Burning Man created a great idea and so
there's a bunch of 10 principles
festivals around the world Esalen great
idea 1962 led to you know a hundred
personal growth retreat centers John so
the Academy is a proof of concept it's
proof of concept and a catalyst for
others social entrepreneurs around the
world to say let's create one in the
Sacred Valley of Peru or in Kyoto Japan
or in the Catskills of New York or do
you think when you say so I can see a
bunch of workarounds to the one location
limitation so when I say one location
does that mean that you will be only
hands-on in one location or do you
envision some type of for lack of a
better descriptor like a franchise model
or an association or a loosely organized
affiliate collection of dozens or
hundreds of properties that chip is
somehow involved with I love your
enterprising mind and I have thought of
all of those that yeah well I just want
to know what would you say like I'm
gonna get to one location is that is
there is there a footnote to that thank
God for cancer yeah honestly I the path
that you're talking about I was in [ __ ]
I was in contract negotiations on a
second location and in discussions on a
third location when I found out about my
cancer on the second day of the book to
her right before you know the TED talk
and six weeks before the modern Elbert
Academy was opening to the public after
a six-month beta period so at that
moment I said no I said and I keep
saying no the thing I will do is create
sort of like the
the startup kit here's how you can
create one not a modern Elder Academy we
may only have one location in the world
but a midlife wisdom school you call it
what you want it to be here's here's how
we can do it you know I don't want to
make you know it could be a consulting
an opportunity but I don't really care
about the money on it I'm lucky enough
thank God for the air B&B last six years
of being there because I don't have to
worry about money that's for sure I just
like the idea that a legacy I can look
to in my life is to create a way for
people to aspire to aging you know aging
is not something that we aspire to and
and yet there are a lot of real plan
expected pleasures of aging do you curve
of happiness is do you know that you
know oh god let's talk about this
so you curve of happiness is so
fascinating it's so at odds with the
societal narrative I think I can see
where this is going so the you curve of
happiness has been proven in every
country but Russia Russia Russia people
get happiest after they die it's a
statistical error clearly but there's
something to that I'm every other
country in the world that has been
studied that what they show is the
following from by age 25 to about age 45
between 45 and 50 depending on the
country is a slow decline in happiness
because of that accumulation because of
that collection of things that we start
to do they prepare us for midlife and
then between 45 and 50 there's this what
brené Brown would call the unraveling
another Texan she's innocent oh yeah she
might even be here Austin's daughters
here yeah exactly so the great
unraveling that happens in midlife where
people actually start to discard things
and they move from the accumulating mode
to the editing mode so that editing mode
the idea that people are moving into
that mode is leads people to get to a
place where they get happier with each
successive decade so people are happier
than in their 50s they're in their 40s
they're actually happier in their 60s
than their 50s and they're happier in
their 70s too than their 60s men start
to flatten out and they're happy
in the second half of their 70s women it
starts happening in their early 80s so
in essence what it's saying because
women women live longer than men is
there's a point at which five to ten
years before you die you actually start
to maybe get a little bit less happy
because they're ten there can be you
know acute health issues going on but
that's fascinating
the fact that we actually get happier as
we get older that is not what you see on
the TV yeah and so I think the idea that
or the aging brain we know the aging
brain we have less recall what's your
name again oh that's right Tim the aging
brain doesn't have recall or it's not as
quick as it used to be but a lot of
people don't know about the aging brain
is it gets more adept at doing a left
brain right brain tango which means
basically the brain shrinks a little bit
as it ages it actually gets it's able to
you're able to as you get older move
from the linear left brain to the
creative right brain much more easily
and more adeptly and what does that lead
to in terms of a positive it leads to
being able to think more synthetically
holistically get the gist of something
so if you want somebody on your team to
actually sort of like here at all and
then distill it down to the wisdom of
like what you they just heard an older
person can do that better than a younger
person younger person isn't much better
at doing focused so why is that relevant
well in the you know that's talked about
Airbnb before money at Airbnb when I
joined six years ago we had third I love
the founders and they were doing an
amazing job and the company we've been
successful without me but when I joined
six years ago and it was you know maybe
one twentieth of the company decides
today we had 30 initiative strategic
initiatives in the year 2013 when I
started and nobody in the company
including the founders could actually
recite all of them so later that year we
did an off-site retreat in New York and
I said to the leadership team of which I
was at now apart I was Brian's mentor
but I was also reporting to him as the
head of global hospitality and strategy
I said we gotta get down to four so for
2014 we are only going to have four
strategic initiatives and so we spent
three days armwrestling over that 123
different potential initiatives we're
and it was that kind of distilling down
I think that how did you do that because
I think a lot of people listening maybe
even one person sitting here talking
I II myself struggle with long lists of
prospective or current projects yeah for
sure right so here you have a fast
growing very very fast Ameen
understatement growing startup they have
a list of how many twenty-something who
knows yeah 23 that we twenty three
initiatives that the twelve members the
strategic initiative the leadership team
thought should be our potential for for
next year so how do you facilitate a
process by which you get that down to
four well it's the intellectual jousting
because you're also kind of the new guy
on the job new guy on the job and I was
the old guy on the job I was twice the
age of the average person in the company
you know twenty years older than I was
21 to 23 years older than all three
founders but I think what they
appreciated was there was an element of
I think a modern elder versus a
traditional elder is the difference is
the modern elder is as curious as they
are wise and it's that curiosity that
opens up possibility and the wisdom is
what distills down the essence of what's
important and it's that essence of
what's important that I think we got to
in that those three days in New York
where he sort of said okay so what is it
that we want to be when we grow up we
want to be a place where people can
belong anywhere we had not said that out
to the public yet but that was the
direction we were going in terms of our
internal mantra of the two words that
defined us we also looked at could we
take the idea of the Airbnb sharing
economy to office space or conference
facilities or anything that had excess
supply there are a lot of natural
sharing economy businesses that could be
created but we also had to ask ourselves
what's the dream of what we want this to
look like five years from now or it may
be even ten years from now because Brian
really wanted us to look very far into
the future and maybe that dream could
help become an editing function so for
me that reminded me of something I did
back in the Jawad Aviv era when I was
running my boutique hotel company when
we were trying to figure out what's our
Ferengi ATAR versus Marriott or even
Kimpton another boutique hotel company
we actually imagined the idea that we
could ask the question what business are
we in because the number one Harvard
Business School this Harvard Business
Review reprint of all time I came from
an article from 1960 called marketing
myopia by Theodore Levitt and then
management theorist and author Peter
Drucker took that idea one step further
he said the most important question any
business leader could ever ask himself
is what business are we in well back in
the may she wanna be Vera we took that
idea of what business are we in and we
turned it into a little bit of a game
the idea was we would be asking
executives or senior leaders to ask
themselves that question in the
following manner so one person would sit
facing the other the person asking the
question would say what business are we
in and the the second person the person
answering would say okay we're in the
boutique hotel business the first person
would say thank you what business are we
in and this time this the per second
person the person answering couldn't not
answer the same way twice and if you do
that five times it really almost is like
an archeological dig to figure out the
essence of your company what's your
soulful differentiator as an
organization this is how we found out
that we were in the identity refreshment
business at Yad Aviv and it was the same
idea that we applied to Airbnb when it
came to an off-site retreat we did
relatively soon after I joined the
company
we sat our executives in pods of two so
they couldn't hear each other any
company could do this and we had them go
through this exercise of asking the
question five times what business are
you in you can't answer the same way
twice and the beauty of this is we
alternate Lee got us to a place over the
course of that day where we came to the
conclusion that belonging anywhere was
really the mantra the definition of what
differentiated us versus the Marriott's
of the world and it was that idea of
belonging anywhere
that helped us to then imagine how could
we edit all of the possibilities of the
things we could go into similarly any
executive or anything any person could
actually that asked this question in a
slightly different way for themselves
the question would be what mastery do
you offer or what mastery can you offer
so have a friend of yours ask that
question of you five times and you'll be
sort of surprised at by the fifth time
you get to ask that question and you've
had to come up with four other answers
before that what kind of revelation you
may have in this archaeological dig that
helps you to mine your own personal
mastery and to go back to the Academy
whether that's a book on the reading
list or an exercise or practice that
attendees have found particularly
valuable is there anything that comes to
mind the people at home might try or
think on well I think you know the basic
premise of the Academy is that in
midlife you need to sort of reframe your
mindset for what's moving forward
there's a famous call young quote about
you can't live the afternoon you of your
life the same way you did the morning
and so speaking to that we have an
exercise around evolution evolving
because the first lesson in my book
wisdom at work making of a modern elder
is to evolve it's the hardest one it's
evolved as the first step involves the
first step the second step is to learn
the third is to collaborate and the
fourth is to counsel and we can come
back to that if you want in a moment but
evolve wow what does that mean it really
means learning to edit what is no longer
serving you so we do a lot of different
exercises around the idea of liminality
which is it being in between two things
some people who might recognize liminal
subliminal yes luminal messages so a
liminal is surviving right there and it
sort of in between two things it's the
transition that frankly a caterpillar to
a butterfly the cocoon is the liminal
state people don't like to be in a
liminal state when you're a kid you're
used to it because everything's in
between everything's you know going from
crawling to walking you know going from
pre-puberty to an adolescent and
teenager but when you're an adult you
don't like to be a liminal and yet we
have all these transitions in men
that actually make us feel liminal so we
do this exercise where there's a whole
counter full of name tags empty nametags
40 of them are empty 120 we've written
different kinds of mindsets ways of
perspective or ways of identifying
yourself that aren't serving you anymore
now if you were to do this on your own
you no one's gonna write those for you
you'll have to write these yourself but
the process of this was process of what
you can do is you actually write down
anything from you know my body is
falling apart or I'm I'm never gonna
meet the you know love of my life so the
there impart beliefs that are no longer
serving you that's great Millennials
rule the world yeah there's a variety of
different things we out there and then
people a lot of times use their own name
tags and what we do is that the
crescendo of this experience this after
that afternoon is people slap like up to
six different name tags on their chests
let me go around the room the name tags
that are already filled out so often as
well as the ones they fly see and if
they have one that they can't find then
they fill out the exactly and so then
you go around a room and you could do
this with like four friends and you go
around the room Sally and look at each
other's nametags and then you ultimately
have a conversation one on one or in a
small group about why these aren't
serving you anymore and how you're gonna
be willing to get liminal and try
transitioning into something new and so
as a result of that we end the afternoon
with a little fire pit we don't walk on
you know any coals or anything like that
we just have people write down what's
the thing that they're ready to evolve
out of that's no longer serving them and
it could be some of the examples of
things like you know what my sense of my
success in in my career will no longer
be my sense of success in life that's an
example of something saying okay I'm
gonna put that in the fire and then let
it burn so that's an example of a
specific kind of exercise we do we do a
lot of mindfulness exercises as well in
terms of helping people to calm their
nervous system can I pause for one
second yeah
the up to six tags on the chest do you
participate in this exercise I do would
you be willing to share some that you
just burned well one of the ones I
wouldn't yeah I mean I you know since
you've heard my health diagnosis I said
like I've recently been given at a scary
health diagnosis and I feel a little
lost so that would be an example of a
name tag another name tag would be yeah
I you know I I think I might never meet
the soulmate that I met six years ago
and no longer in that relationship I am
in the relationship but it's it's turned
into a different kind of relationship
another one could be another one that
I've written and and then ultimately
burned is it's time to take down the
scaffolding of my ego so what does that
mean it means like over the course of my
teen years and growing up you build the
ego we sort of create this container and
ego can be a very healthy thing it can
actually create the separation it's the
thing that actually helps us to know who
we are but it is a bit of a scaffolding
and like what I mean by taking down the
scaffolding of the ego is really sort of
saying behind that is something that's
really amazing it's a soul to heart it's
and I'm no longer going to let my ego
sort of be the thing that I lead with
and how and then I you know come up with
a list of things how that showed how
what are the practices or ways of being
that actually have to change in order
for that to be the case so those are
some examples just off the cuff I'd I
wish I had a list right you have do you
have people prepare for the time at
modern Elder Academy in any way or do
they show up and that's sort of time
zero when what else begin they've got to
read the book wisdom at work the making
of modern elder and they do two
exercises one which is an identity
cleanse where they actually talk to
their friends about what parts what
parts of their identity work and what
parts that identity don't work so well
so they actually get some feedback and
then and this is before they arrive and
then they do have values inventory of
like what are the values that are most
important and
ranking them so they try to get clear
going into it what are the values now
later in the week they often go back to
that list and say my god now that I've
had some time to think about this my
values list is a little different and so
they asked themselves then how can they
how are we asked them and we we work
with them because because after people
leave that group of 12 to 18 people in
the cohort they literally for some of
the groups have a weekly zoom call every
single week so they're sort of
accountability partners and and people
who can sort of help them say okay yeah
you said your values you know number one
value is this and you know now it looks
like it's not there anymore what's going
on so that's part of what happens to
what what would be example values that
people might then put in order an
example could I mean some of the most
obvious ones are family religious
beliefs making a difference in the local
community or or you know trying to
change the perspective on climate change
so these are those are some of them the
there's other ones with just like ways
of being which are being feeling free so
that that's not example would say that's
not a value but that's sort of a way of
being it could be a way being priority
yeah so there's that's what they are so
it's a mixture of I would say values and
ways of being and we have like a list of
60 of them and then they come up with
their top five and then stack rank those
top five and and then over the course
the week we we don't force them to go
back to it but there's some exercises we
do that allow them to on their own sort
of look at see and see how those have
changed would you be open to talking
about family for a few minutes yeah okay
so I would love to hear your some
backstory that I don't know and then
have some questions about yeah current
current day yes see you are openly gay
yes when have you been openly gave kinda
from the get-go or when when did that so
I was become something that was too
publicly that you felt comfortable
publicly 22 and I came up so I was
undated women girls you know I I was
very actively sexually in my high school
and so but I knew behind the scenes like
there was something there I grew up with
a father who I love both my parents are
still living there 81 but my dad was
Stephen senior I was Stephen junior the
chip off the old block and my dad was a
captain in the Marine Reserve - hard
core you know dude and I was the oldest
and the only boy and so I was meant to
be like the the mini version of dad
so the my process of being Eagle Scout
like my dad
all-american water polo player it you
know in high school and then playing
water polo at Stanford student body
president all this stuff was like I was
on the path to be just actually my dad
and I talked about this recently he said
chip all I wanted you to do is be a
better version of me and that was so
interesting to hear that I always knew
that was the case but I never heard him
that was one year say it's like dad I
know and that like [ __ ] with my mind
so I did everything I could to sort of
just be this better version of dad
and then in I was in the fraternity and
at Stanford and that's where it's like
messing with my mind being a fraternity
with a bunch of guys who I had some
attraction to but I wasn't doing
anything about it and I was dating a
couple different women and it was in
between my first and second year
Business School I was 22 years old
living in New York working for Morgan
Stanley you know investment banker by
day and at night walking into my first
gay bar and that's when it was like you
know like Wizard of Oz Munchkinland you
know went from black and white to
Technicolor I was like oh wow this feels
a little worse this may be a thing yeah
a thing and so but you know back then
Wow I mean I came out the summer that
Newsweek had you know the the cover
story about you know the gay the gay
cancer would be called AIDS and so it
was a really really not an easy time to
come out certainly not an easy time to
come out in terms of the world that we
live in today compared to then in terms
of especially someone who's like you
know hardcore business guy and so when I
started my company at 26 you know people
knew I was gay and the sort of
unusual thing to have sort of a founder
CEO of Gallo's I was living since when I
was a boutique Oh talk up and it's a lot
like that made it a little easier and
yeah so I've ever since age 22 pretty
much just you know been you know an out
really gay man and have had to two long
relationships and now have a couple of
sons with a lesbian couple I wanted to
ask you about that so how did how did
that come about
so the women live in Houston
Laura has been a longtime friend of mine
and she asked me it was her timing was
perfect she asked me three weeks before
I was selling my company she wanted Eve
and I was like the mama and the Papa I
want Aviv so I didn't have a co-founder
ran it for 24 years knew almost
everybody in the company 3,500 employees
I had a lot of parent energy that had
gone into my company and I was wondering
like wow what's gonna happen when I like
step away from that and three weeks
before I we made it public that I was
actually excelling she approached me and
I'd been approached before by lesbians
who wanted my sperm that you know but
I'd always said no and so this time I
said yes and I and so the idea was
Frankie they're gonna be in Houston I'll
be the sperm donor I don't have any
legal rights financial obligations and
we'll see how it goes in terms of
whether the boys or the kids boys or
girls will know who their dad is so is
that that sort of like okay I mean it
pretty transactional although you know
probably a little bit more like okay
maybe it'll be more than that but let's
see it as we go
well they ended up the two women ended
up having two boys and more than
anything I think they the the women who
you know they live in the state of Texas
and so the rules around this are tough
it Texas this a little bit more of a
conservative State and so there was some
worry that ok well I'm the I'm the real
biological dad and so can the
non-biological mom be a mom and long
story short as we got to a place where
it was beautiful they there they knew
that my intentions were not
to like be the full-time dad or to even
be in a co-parenting role I was there to
be the boy's dad when I'm there and I'm
there you know a moderate amount and
they come down to Baja a lot and it's
been beautiful it's and you know it's
been a great way to give these boys a
lot of love and in essence three parents
instead of two number of different
follow-up questions so the first is is
reflecting on something you said which
is I'd been asked before and I said no
so I I had been asked a few years ago by
very close friend of mine if I would be
a sperm donor for his sister who had
just gotten out of a very long
relationship who had been kind of strung
along by a guy until she was in her late
30s and I thought very very seriously
about it and I'd never considered it
before thought very seriously was going
to do it and then had a friend of mine
who has had at that time one young child
now as to and he said Tim if you do that
you are going to need and want to be
involved in some fashion like it's not I
know you well enough it's not gonna sit
well with you like you're not going to
be able to go hands-free and so I
decided not to do it why did you change
your mind like why did that why did you
say yes in this case and know in
previous cases I think this idea that
literally I had my psychologically
analyzed myself and I thought I really
have had all the parent energy being the
mentor and you know almost father figure
for so many people in the company and
that was gonna change and I didn't
necessarily understand what kind of gap
that would create in my life so the
timing was perfect so I understand what
your point of view and yet I was in a
place where there was a part of me that
was thirsty for it you know and because
the the women were so self-sufficient
about how they wanted to do this I
figured ok it you know let's see it and
I didn't I didn't know whether it was
going to turn out as it's turned out
which is I'm much more integrated in the
boy's life how did that come to be I
think it was partly because they know
that me to boy isn't matter I think you
know and the and
if they'd had the two girls I had two
girls let's say I'm not sure if it would
have been different I might think my
thinking is it might have been different
I think the fact that they're boys like
they want their dad and they want to go
pal around with dad on the beach and
things like that you know I think that
that had some influence maybe although
we've never talked about that but more
than anything I just you know you just
start loving you know these these kids I
know I had had a foster son when I was
28 I became a foster parent to a 13 year
old from the Tenderloin that that
district where my first hotel is and
whose father's black mom's white and you
know basically and he ended up homeless
because his parents were just not very
responsible and so I had had an
experience of being a parent but it was
a really unusual experience it was me
and my partner my Israeli partner who I
was with at that time and is one of my
best friends now and here's this kid
who's darker skinned movie who's
straight at age 13 moving in with two
white gay men and it's like it was
perfect for a sitcom it taught me a
little bit about parenting in the early
days very different experience though so
I but I do think that this idea of
having younger people who need your
tutelage and love helps us get out of
our ego it is absolutely you know
there's no doubt that you know it's a
Zen practice to actually be with a
little child and they take all of your
attention
mm-hmm so but I you know I think it's
been certainly the process of how we
define and create family has certainly
evolved a lot in the last three or four
decades how are you thinking about
parenting in the sense that are you are
you going instinctive or you have you
been have you read books on the subject
you know there's a lot there's some
blogs that I've seen in the past and I
at the end of the day at the instinctive
to me is best but I but that you know
between stimulus and response it was
important because it's really easy to be
reactive with a kid who's just acting
out and sure it's a little more
complicated in my case because I'm not
with the boys every day
whereas
the moms are and so I also don't want to
pull rank and sort of do anything that
that suggests their approach to
parenting is not my approach so I'm
pretty much instinctively trying to work
with with with their approach as well
you know there's a beautiful Dan Gilbert
TED talk about the fact that we all
underestimate how much changes ahead of
us at every frankly at every different
era of our life so I think the idea of
embracing liminality and sort of saying
yes I'm moving to Austin yeah yes a
couple years ago I'm moving to Baja
and so when you embrace it and you sort
of see it as just the nature of life it
allows for it to allows you for you to
see some of the secret beauty in some of
the things you you might be resisting so
I would say I'm still liminal I would
say the chapter wise I do think my
process of moving from being in the
trenches helping to run Airbnb for four
years and then two years now is a
strategic adviser a huge change in terms
of my day-to-day living when I was
day-to-day there versus just sort of
advising Bryan and the founders on on
things now so I'd say that was a healthy
change but I don't know more than
anything I'm just curious I Peter
Drucker taught me that curiosity is the
elixir of life and I really believe that
and I think that the the thing that
makes a modern elder different than a
traditional elders a traditional elder
was about being revered there's about
reverence you revere drill and in
respected you elder it's not about
reverence anymore it's about relevance
and relevance requires understanding the
modern day world not just spouting
wisdom that sometimes is timeless and
age-old but it's actually knowing how to
fit that age-old wisdom into the context
of modern-day problems and so I think if
I can't spend the rest of my life being
both curious and wise almost
simultaneously that is the potent
alchemy that will make me hopefully a
very happy person yeah but also someone
who can actually in
other people in positive ways as well
curious and wise and maybe also unrushed
so you can watch that oil yeah watch
that oil going down the stairs yeah yeah
what or watch the whales you know nature
is such a teacher and I gotta say I mean
being here in Austin there's some really
beautiful natural parts of Austin and I
think anybody who doesn't get romance by
nature on a regular basis is missing
that lyrical sense of what life is meant
to be yeah definitely so I've just a few
rapid-fire questions they don't require
rapid-fire answers but I always like to
ask at least a handful of these so the
first one outside of your own books what
book or books have you gifted the most
to other people and why
well other than man's search for meaning
which is probably my number one gift
recently the last couple years
there's a book called the hundred year
life 100 your life written by a couple
Brits and it it sure says imagine the
future where the average person lives to
a hundred how is that going to change on
a personal and societal basis it's a
really interesting observational book
the happiness curve which we talked
about earlier it's about the the U curve
of happiness is what we call it but the
name of the book is by Jonathan Roush is
called the happiness curve that's become
a favorite to gift I also love Danny
Meyer at the restaurant tour yeah and
he's got and he's got one of the best
books on hospitality ever written which
is called setting the table for him yeah
so Danny Meyer what's what's the list I
might be getting yes we will certainly
have Shake Shack for that you didn't
square hospitality and you didn't from
Gramercy Grammer so that's what I'm
looking for it's a friend of mine used
to work on the line there and yeah
Gramercy Park fascinating fascinating
guy yeah also some good sort of
philosophical food to chew on right I
mean his practical in philosophical in
terms of let's say eliminating will
speak in philosophical thank you Marcus
Aurelius meditations I have given
a way to a number of people there we go
you know in Seneca there's a Seneca book
about about the short life I can tell on
the shortness a shortness of life you
know when things he says in that book is
he says it says something about the fact
that it's not so much the shortness of
life it's how we waste it yeah and I
think there's something to that in terms
of like what what percentage of your
life is being spent wasted also a
longevity thing that I've been thinking
about lately is like imagine what age
you're gonna live to and on the online
like jibbety sites say I'm gonna live
till I'm 98 and then ask yourself how
much of your adult life if you start
counting at age 18 is still ahead of you
in fact for me at age 58 I'm at half
time if I live to 98 and when you start
realizing you're only 50% of your way
through your adult life you take up
surfing at 56 or 57 yeah you take up
Spanish which I'm doing now because I
live in Mexico part of the time better
learn Spanish me espanol is muy Malo
so yeah or you write two-thirds of the
books that you know we're going to write
in your life as Peter Drucker after 65
yeah if you could put a a word a message
quote a question anything non-commercial
on a billboard metaphorically speaking
to get it in front of billions of people
is there anything that comes to mind
that you might put on that billboard
well you mentioned Oscar Wilde earlier I
think one of my favorite quotes of all
time is be yourself everyone else is
taken my Oscar Wilde quote I would
probably slap up there you know I don't
know I think the the thing I probably
would yeah I play stick with that be
yourself everyone else is taken ya chip
this is so much fun yeah it's really
nice to see you yeah it's great to be
here and it's gonna be the first of many
times not necessarily show but just
hanging out yeah oh yeah we're neighbors
yeah at this point and people can say
hello on Twitter at chip Conley Facebook
chip Conley author LinkedIn chip Conley
SF and we'll link to all this in the
show notes so for people who are
watching or listening to this at
Blagh forward slash podcasts you can
find links to all of this who just
search for chip also you have modern
elder in Academy org the people can
check out anything else parting comments
thoughts suggestions anything you'd like
to mention before we I think I think I
would just finish by just saying that
the more we fear aging the more we're
playing on the playing field of the
youth and there's nothing wrong with
that but if you if your intent is to
just stay looking young the rest of your
life you're playing on the wrong playing
field it's a losing battle at some point
and what some of us are embarrassed to
see people who are continue to plan that
playing field what I think people need
to recognize is whether it's the depth
of our emotions the depth of our
spiritual connection with ourselves and
something bigger than ourselves these
are the things that actually start to
grow as we age and it's part of the
reason why we get happier as we get
older you know and you mentioned the
anxiety equals let me get this right
don't stop don't don't tell me it's
anxiety equals uncertainty times hope
powerlessness yes and that ties into
Marcus really really nicely as well
because it's you know in a sense you
know this stoic philosophical system
certainly as practiced by Marcus
Aurelius entailed a lot of separating
what you can control from what you can
and the possible from the inevitable and
certainly it's hard to think of someone
offhand who thought of death and
mortality more than Marcus Aurelius but
but learn to befriend it in a way yeah
and not to to fight something that sort
of left to become this amorphous source
of anxiety can really be paralyzing when
is your doing right now learning to
embrace it and live in the liminal
embrace the elder on the word I'm trying
to like bring back bring back the word
to elder and and separate from elderly
which is to
that's the last 10 years your life well
for now modern elder chip thank you so
much for the time thank you Jim
yeah I'm going to be really fun and to
everyone listening and anybody watching
thank you for joining us and until next
time be well be safe experiment often
and learn to live in the liminal pick up
surfing or Spanish or something else
that you've been putting off it's not
too late thanks everybody
you